this was a couch trip a journey to sit
the Scots down and ask them the question
that in a hundred days they'll answer in
writing should Scotland be an
independent country we started in Orkney
the islands near the top so near they
used to belong to Norway what do they
say here about independence for Scotland
I'm gonna vote no well I'm very
undecided at the present moment I feel
at the economy the country is very good
at the moment I'm they sure if they can
do it alone financially what do you
undecided oh yes
a undecided trust no but I'll have to
look into it see what space we're all in
if we do get it I'm gonna show freedom
no I don't want independence because
that's what William Wallace said we want
freedom is that what you want yes
freedom the better together we
complement one another on Orkneys Locke
Harry we found Shetlands Alec Miller a
visitor who'll vote for an independent
Scotland and maybe one day for an
independent Shetland love my view is I'm
definitely voting voting YES in the
referendum should Shetland be
independent from from Scotland I hardly
think that's likely in at this stage
it's maybe something that might develop
if Scotland becomes independent there is
a body of opinion that wants
independence for Shetland Orkney and the
Western Isles politicians straddling the
referendum debate one more powers and
autonomy whatever happens in September
because we feel that they were
innovative and self-reliant people here
we've demonstrated in the past that we
can get on with things to our best
advantage it allowed the freedom to do
this next stop for the sofa the Scottish
British mainland
peterhead is Europe's largest whitefish
port at morning market debate over
Scotland's future is defined by the
politics of Europe and resentment over
Brussels control of a declining industry
I'm voting to stay in the United Kingdom
I'm keen are undecided I'm hoping where
I get the chance to vote and I
Westminster election next year get
conservatives reelected who will then
give me an EU referendum whether we stay
in or out a Europe if you look at
Ireland there are independent country
the fishing is decreasing so how how are
they host Scotland going to get a better
deal and then Ireland out of Europe we
traveled on to Scotland central belt to
Glasgow the yes campaign needs to make
ground in this traditional labor
heartland if it's to stand a chance of
success it also needs to overcome its
difficulty in convincing women to vote
for change i think women just have a
more sensible bit things you know guys
will just see you know let's do it
anyway but women i think and we can we
be up for the pros and cons change
that's the most important thing changing
things that can benefit Scotland as well
I think it's time for changing and
dependence definitely orsa because we'd
get so much going for us
I'm having to set an ash tree and beg to
make money because anytime I can see of
government gets done maybe she's good I
got and they brought against it because
I've been to few talks and stuff and I
don't know if they'll be able to call
many ways
in the borders we ran into a traffic jam
this was hikes 500th common riding a
celebration of the Battle of horns haul
when local youths fought off an English
raiding party I'm gonna vote to stay
with the Union I feel strongly that
Scotland is part of the Union and should
remain so it's gonna happen eventually
you might not be this time may not be
the next thing but we're on a kind of
inevitable trajectory towards it hey
that's what you'd want independence yes
absolutely the view from the sofa makes
it clear that Scotland is a nation
divided on its political path and
September result will necessarily change
that they are the thoughts of a country
pondering its future a hundred days
until the one day when Scots will hold
their destiny in their own hands and
take a decision on the constitutional
landscape that lies ahead James Matthews
Sky News in Edinburgh